flood waters have begun to recede on the
coast of oaxaca in southern mexico
residents however are still reeling from
the impact of hurricane agatha
i have nothing left nothing to eat now
i'm going to see what i can find but
nobody has anything left
agatha was a powerful category 2
hurricane when it made landfall late
monday evening
and authorities say the death toll is
likely to rise while the search for
those missing continues
based on the reports we've received
we've made the decision to provide
services to the most affected areas most
importantly the coast of oaxaca
the challenges faced by those emergency
teams are daunting
heavy rainfall from agatha caused
widespread flooding and mudslides
state and federal authorities say
efforts remain underway to clear roads
and provide desperately needed aid to
thousands of people affected
[Music]
well all our water is dirty and we don't
have anything to drink but we're waiting
for support we need at least water food
or whatever they can give us because you
lost everything here we don't have
anything the clothes and dishes are wet
everything was lost
though hurricane agatha has mostly
dissipated over the mountains of
southern mexico weather forecasters
warned the remaining thunderstorms could
regroup into a tropical depression or
even a tropical storm
if so agatha's name would change to alex
becoming the first named storm of the
2022 atlantic hurricane season
potentially bringing heavy rain and wind
to the u.s state of florida by the end
of the week manuel rapalo al jazeera